bonjour eric zemmour bonjour daniel mach
on vient d'annoncer un beauvau pour la
police nationale c'est à dire une sorte
de grande consultation sur l'avenir de
la police et vous ça vous rappelle cette
phrase de clemenceau quand on veut
enterrer un problème on crée une
commission
oui vous vous souvenez de cette boutade
célèbre ça m'a fait tout de suite penser
à ça mais dans un dans un contexte
différent ce dire que la boutade de
clemenceau on sait c'est dans le cadre
de la 3ème république donc le régime
parlementaire traditionnels et qui était
qu' il y avait le parlement qui régnait
qui gouvernait et quand il y avait un
gros problème vont créer une commission
pour enterrer en pour enterrer la
question pour noyer les poissons pour
renvoyer pour parler pendant des mois et
puis on l'opinion avait oublié là
aujourd'hui nous ne sommes plus dans ce
monde là nous ne sommes plus dans le
monde du régime parlementaire les
parlementaires n'ont plus de pouvoir
donc créé une commission parlementaire
ça ne sert à rien donc la 5ème
république
la 5eme blick je dirais décadente car
c'était pas justement la volonté du
général de gaulle c'est que la 5ème
république décider tranche l'assekrem
public décadente a inventé le le
grenelle le grenelle vous souvenez du
grenelle 2 mai 68 ont réuni les
syndicats les ministres et hauts
fonctionnaires pour l'essai de sortir de
la grève générale qui règne à l'époque
et ben l'agglo grenelle a fait des
petits il ya le grenelle quand on veut
parler problèmes sociaux salaires etc
mais il ya le ségur de la santé vous
souvenez ya pas longtemps et puis là
maintenant on nous invente le beauvau de
la police ronde on va faire ça pour tous
les ministères ça marcherait aussi bien
qu'est-ce que cela signifie
cela signifie que d'abord pourquoi
pardon je fais les questions ça marche
pas pourquoi et manioc de la composent
se bat pour sortir du piège qu'il s'est
lui-même tendu c'est à dire qu'il avait
nommé
darmanin pour remplacer castaner pour
renouer le lien avec la police qui
fulminait contre castaner comme arman a
fait le boulot honnêtement il a défendu
les policiers bec et ongles même dans
les pires aux polémiques et c'est
emmanuel macron lui même qui vient
saccagé le travail de son ministre de
l'intérieur en reprenant devant une
chaîne youtube je crois brut c'est ça
c'est son nom tout là toute la
terminologie toute la de l'extrême
gauche de la france est soumise alors on
est passé de des violences policières
aux discriminations aux contrôles au
faciès
enfin bref qui ce qui a ulcéré et
légitimement les policiers et leur
syndicat et donc tout est à refaire
et alors là on nous sort du chapeau 1
beauvau de la police enfin vous
reconnaissez quand même que il ya un
sujet autour de la violence et de la
police qu'il s'agisse des violences
dites policière ou des violences dont
est victime la police
je crois pas qu'on règle le problème en
se mettant autour d'une table c'est ça
la différence c'est que je pense qu'il
n'y a pas de violences policières je
récuse le terme car la police c'est
l'état et l'état a le monopole de la
violence légitime donc il peut y avoir
un policier qui est violent ça aurait pu
en discuter mais là les termes violences
policières effet vous savez la
sémantique c'est très important surtout
pour l'extrême gauche qui en jouent
depuis des décennies et pour nous
imposer des concepts qui n'existait pas
avant
on passe d'abord par les mots pour
imposer la réalité et violences
policières ça veut dire que l'état n'a
plus cette légitime il a cette
légitimité la de la violence et ça veut
dire qu'on désarme les tailles quand on
désarme la police ont des armes et à
quand on désarme l'état ont détruit la
france surtout dans la situation
française qu'on connaît actuellement
c'est fait exprès donc en reprenant ce
terme là même si il il est là il pensait
subtil complexe qu il déconstruit qu'il
reprend qu'il nuance etc
c'est donner acte et se soumettre à l
extrême gauche rose islamo gauchiste et
à la france insoumise voilà ça c'est
c'est une chose qui est pour moi il faut
rappeler finalement pour vous le en même
temps macro nist on pensait que c'était
une idée de génie mais ça pourrait être
un piège oui le en même temps qui nous
faisait considérer que emmanuel macron
était un esprit subtil et complexe qui
pouvait concilier l'inconciliable et
donc ré concilier les inconciliables
s'avère en fait une stratégie de la
non-décision delà du refus de trancher
du refus de choisir et parce que tout
simplement aujourd'hui choisir ses
discriminer qui est un mot tabou et
choisir ses contraintes qui est un autre
mot tabou qui nous ramène tout reprendre
la logorrhée ridicule du politiquement
correct aux pires heures de notre
histoire
c'est à dire cette société horrible
verticale patriarcale en vous connaissez
tous les maux alors qu'on veut justement
imposé une société horizontale
consensuelle où personne ne peut imposer
sa décision où l'état ne peut rien
imposer où l'état n'est plus en surplomb
de la société comme dans les sociétés
traditionnelles et comment république
mais au contraire que l'état et le
l'obligé est soumis aux individus qui à
qui il doit donner des droits sans fin
et qui qui lui impose son pouvoir leur
pouvoir
merci eric zemmour